[Music]
if you entrust me with the presidency
i will draw on the best of us not the
worst
i'll be an ally of the light not the
darkness
united we can and will overcome
this season of darkness in america we'll
choose hope over fear
facts over fiction fairness over
privilege
that was joe biden reading really big
font well remember when joe biden
promised
hope and optimism well just six months
into his presidency
optimism is at an all-time low a brand
new poll coming out just now
shows that 55 of the public are
pessimistic about where the country is
headed
a 20-point decline from april that's an
abc news poll fox news contributor lara
trump is here to
react laura thank you so much for being
here this morning those numbers brand
new
did they surprise you at all now i'm i'm
actually surprised they're not worse
than that
uh it has really been become clear that
people have major
buyers remorse uh with our most popular
president
in the history of america 81 million
votes remember guys
i say that for secrecy yes and a half
full cnn audience they couldn't even
fill a small auditorium right
right that's exactly right but i mean
the reality is it's only taken
six months for joe biden alongside
kamala harris to really start
to run america straight into the ground
you see how quickly we have had
gas prices skyrocketing massive
inflation
the the reality is that we are paying
people to stay home instead of going to
work small businesses
are having a really hard time coming
back right now we are looking weak now
in the
eyes of not just our adversaries but our
allies
around the world we have had at least a
million
illegal immigrants flow of over our
southern border and that's just that we
know of
now six months into the biden harris
administration
so no i am not surprised that the
majority of the american people are
pessimistic
about the future of america and how sad
because it wasn't too long ago
under president trump that this was all
reversed it was the other way
people were very optimistic there were
jobs flourishing
we felt very positive about the future
of america and now here we are
so um really sad but again not
surprising we kind of knew
if you gave the reins to a man like joe
biden who who has a hard time figuring
out exactly where he is
this is the result yeah for sure at
least we don't have those mean tweets
that's a bonus
uh you know that's the upside apparently
of all of this when you talk about
buyer's remorse though laura you talked
to a lot of people
what aspect of that what what policy do
you think people
are missing the most which leads to this
pessimism which by the way
pessimism when the media is covering for
them at every step
also yeah it's true well i mean i think
it's different for different people look
my parents are small business owners and
i can tell you that that they along with
a lot of americans
who have small businesses have had a
really hard time
finding workers again back to the point
about paying people
to stay home you think about the result
of allowing people to just free flow
over our southern border it trickles
down to every
facet of american life our school system
our health care system
jobs across the country um the fact that
we really
are are just not respected again i think
uh anymore around the world like we were
under president donald trump
he exuded strength and to so many people
joe biden
is the opposite of that he exudes
weakness around america
uh you know whenever we're talking about
re-engaging with iran and the iran
nuclear deal
when we get back with the paris climate
accord things that president trump stood
up to and said enough is enough standing
up to china
and our adversaries all across the world
you're not seeing that happen
with joe biden and then what about joe
being the great uniter
of people in fact we have seen the
skyrocketing crime
uh you know the murders going through
the roof all over our major american
cities
what happened to that i thought we were
gonna bring everybody together joe
instead
the opposite has happened
reconciliation in the u.s senate real
quick uh
we just got information that we know joe
biden stopped building the wall what we
didn't know
is that it cost american taxpayers two
billion dollars so far
not to build the wall three million a
day
and so apparently just another example
of us paying people
or paying contracts not to i don't know
build the wall that we need
i mean i've never heard of something
more ridiculous you know you go down to
the southern border
and you see that that president trump
had built most of the wall by the way it
was already paid for
all joe biden had to do was nothing and
he could have just sat back
and it would have been finished it would
have been completed but you have these
small sections of wall
where you have the the supplies laid
down on the ground
all they've got to do is stand them up
instead we are paying as you just said
two billion dollars to have somebody
come and guard
those materials instead of erecting the
full wall
look you can dispute a lot of things but
you can't dispute that under president
trump
we had really really low numbers of
border crossings he had reversed the
situation
on our southern border and now under joe
biden
what a complete and total joke the
taxpayers are paying for this and guys
that's not even going
to you know talk about what we're paying
to bus and fly the illegal immigrants
after they cross our southern border to
any city usa
it is also costing us millions and
probably billions of dollars who knows
what that cost is you're so right
laura trump thank you so much for your
time this morning appreciate it